November 2014 I made a video about free
software and did some video editing and
then people have said since would you
ever go back to editing with free
software and I tried and failed
miserably but they're not found that Rob
is doing editing on free software so
well what be gone well so I before I
started my channel I'd never edited any
video at all so I just got started with
kdenlive kate is a cape KDE in live can
live under a Hertz panel I said kdenlive
because this is the piece of software I
used actually right and that's kind of
why I used it because I hadn't heard of
I hadn't gotten into open source video
editing before I heard it was fairly
good it was the one you'd used so you
know I went for that as it were what the
vision is a video that I just um
uploaded just recently which is fairly
typical no I think it's quite standard
but on the other hand I have no idea
because I have never done video editing
for well from my point of view that
looks like a very sensible working
timeline it's like using different
tracks for different things can you show
us a bit what sort of thing you'll be
doing another like here for example I'm
compositing in some thumbnails of the
other of the computer file videos
because it's relevant to those back in
the day these would have been
annotations you know it would be
clickable YouTube doesn't do that
anymore sad times its office to the home
where them what what view what you have
to use so hardware is this did you make
especially I did yeah just because I
didn't have a desktop at all
I tried using my laptop this one which
is just really really not up to it on
account of being extremely light and
thin and just not made for any kind of
heavy lifting so I put together this
machine and it's pretty it's pretty
standard here's me looking at the
components that I'm putting in it okay
so it's very soft the shelf stuff right
yeah pretty standard the only thing I
wanted was a lot of round of 16 gig of
ram so
not going to run out doing basic video
editing and a solid-state drive a 240
gig solid-state drive to do that holds
my files temporarily while I'm working
on them for performance and then a
terabyte of hard disk to keep sorry 2
terabytes apparently saved here 2
terabytes I'm looking at the video again
one thing that I run up against is my
lack of experience with new Linux
distros and the irony is that that was
kind of what was testing out throughout
all of this sure so till considering
what you've got going there because you
know a lot more about these sorts of
things an ID yeah so I use I've been
through a lot of different distributions
I started off with a bun - because
everybody starts off with a bun - and
then what else did I try I went to
crunchbang because I thought a bun - bun
- got really I think it got really heavy
past a certain point it was including
too much stuff and being too graphical
and in-your-face and I use Linux Mint
for a while because that was very nice
why I'm using here is Manjaro which is
based on arch but arch is a real arch is
like I look on I know people get almost
religious about these things yet not
they're almost about it people people
get literally unambiguously religious
about these things but you're a real
console jockey could anybody use this
kind of distress this kind of a I mean I
don't use that term in a derasa quite
but I know you know what you do or the
console and yet me I need Geary's right
right right yeah the console is my
preferred way of interacting with my
computer most of the time but right
right so I'm running one jar right would
you large based but arch you kind of
have to build from the ground up the
idea of arch is by the time you have a
running Arch Linux installation you
really understand Linux because you have
to you know you've sort of it's not like
you hit install and then you go off and
have a cup of tea and come back and
you're done
you have to actually make all of the
decisions and run the commands to set up
the system so this light you are
compiling your own kernels and stuff not
white but that kind of thing yeah you're
putting a lot of time into it so you
have complete control you have complete
customization everything is exactly how
you want it but you've got to know what
you're doing
whereas Manjaro is arch based but has
some sensible defaults so somebody's
done some of that work for you yeah so
you can still use the art repositories
and things in the arch wiki which is
amazing like the art wiki is so good for
all kinds of information about all kinds
of software in the next things but you
don't have to sit there and go through
this long installation process and all
of these decisions that you're not
really sure what you want you know so
that's it's about fragile I kind of I do
like it the update thing it's very it's
a rolling release thing so you're
continuously getting updates it's not
like you then install the next version
it's like every day there's a couple of
updates in your system continually
updates but that doesn't mean sometimes
stuff can just break because some update
has broken compatibility with something
with something else and you have to sit
there and figure it out when you want it
to be doing work that was something that
got me a little bit was that I had a
workflow already in place he's kind of
said to workflow up from scratch how
does that work flow broken sometimes
because of this have you have you been
kind of back to square one sometimes um
I had a problem with the laptop actually
where an update broke my USB microphone
it broke
I ended up in a weird situation where
the USB audio kernel module was not
present anymore
because it had upgraded past itself or
something and I wasn't sure it turns out
it was fine but it made me very nervous
because because the the modules I had
were for a different version of the
kernel so I guess the kernel had updated
and I'd removed the old modules
and replace them with the new ones but I
hadn't been paying attention when I was
running the updates so I didn't know if
my system was actually okay or if there
was some serious problem it turns out I
rebooted everything was fine it booted
up with the new kernel version it found
a couple modules everything worked
perfectly well but because I wasn't sure
if I'd completely destroyed my system
accidentally with an update I couldn't
trust that if I rebooted it it would
actually come up so I made a full backup
while it was running and stuff like that
just didn't you know to be on the safe
side but that did cost me some time
obviously and anyone sensible would have
had a continuous update process and
would have not cared at all if at any
moment their machine exploded and you
know always drink enough water and get
your 5 vegetables a day and wake up at 6
a.m. for a run but not everybody's like
that I'm most comfortable doing most of
my work in a terminal or a text editor
obviously if you're doing graphics or
video you need a user interface a
graphical user interface but most of the
time I find a terminal is more it's more
efficient it's got a it's got a learning
curve obviously but when you're good
with it I think you can be better and
faster than doing it through a GUI in
most of the time and I think people who
are really good with Garry's don't
actually use the mouse very much like
they learn the keyboard shortcuts and so
if you're learning how to do everything
in a keyboard anyway you don't really
need all those little buttons it's kind
of a it's like a second Stein's ladder
some philosophers ladder you climb off
the ladder and then you throw it away
when you're done with it
right through but if you can climb you
don't need the ladder so but yes Manjaro
is usually easier to use than this
because I run a tiling window manager
called awesome window manager which I
like because it makes efficient use of
the screen space so here you see I've
got my text editor here which is sublime
I have to
terminals and if I want another terminal
I open it and it opens right here so the
number of pixels on this screen that
aren't one of the programs I'm using is
almost none right
whereas if I put it into here now it's
in a more sort of normal mode where I
can move the windows all like this and I
can be like I'm harming this this
program now in that program like this is
closer to the way that people usually
use Windows was right but a lot of time
I've got windows that are over the top
of one another they're obscuring one
another
I've got bits of my screen where I'm not
there's nothing so that's how I do most
of my stuff and you can obviously you
can adjust these like you can move them
in and out and change their size
relative to each other for whatever you
need
yeah that's the window manager it's
called awesome and I like it a lot but
the point is if I were using Ubuntu with
awesome window manager what you would
see on the screen would be basically
identical because the window manager is
determining pretty much everything on
the screen so the fact that I'm using
majora underneath isn't that relevant
from an aesthetic perspective I'm
showing my complete ignorance here that
what what exactly would be different
under the hood then for a completely
different distro
it's the way it's the choices of
software that do the system level stuff
like it would something like with
something like Windows everything pretty
much everything it comes from Microsoft
until you get up to user space like you
get to choose you know which web browser
you use but it comes with the one File
Explorer and one like I don't know file
system network manager like all of the
bits that build the operating system
they come with it and they are not
really removable or interchangeable
whereas Linux you have the kernel which
actually doesn't do that much
and then everything else that makes up
the operating system is other pieces of
software the other projects made by
other people and you can what a
distribution does is it picks a load of
those that work well together and post
them all together into a guest room with
you know sensible configurations so that
they all know about one another and
ideally and they all work together well
but any part of that system could in
principle be pulled out and replaced by
a different program that does the same
job it's just like that the standard
thing where you can choose you can
choose how you're going to you know what
your web browser is you can choose
whether you're going to use you know
Libre Office or Microsoft Word it's that
but all the way down almost all the way
down I had a face as a teenager and I
think a lot of people did where I was
really into it and I learned everything
about how to put my system together in
all the different little bits and now
all of that knowledge is out-of-date and
useless because I didn't keep up with it
because once I found an operating system
setup that works for me highly I
realized I don't care it's interesting
but there comes a point where you're
using your system to work and you want
to use whatever works right the thing is
this just works I need to emphasize that
because I I got this PC to put it
together it booted the first time we
expected it to you know and then I
installed Mandara on it uneventful
process I used you know I literally just
went with pac-man - there's kdenlive
enter that's one thing that changes the
package manager like different
distributions obviously use different
repositories and different package
managers so you get your software from
different places they all do roughly the
same thing though anyway I just install
clean life and it worked off the bat
like I import my videos I import my
audio i sync them up I added them I hit
export I use hear it I don't hear
exporting hit render I go to this one
adjust the WebM
because that's normal
and it has all these extra options about
you know how you're going to do the you
know what the exact command is and all
of this stuff I ignored all of that I
hit render to file it renders it's
perfect you upload it to YouTube it
knows what to do like I didn't have to
it worked out of box that's what I'm
saying it was and so it's weird because
our experiences were so different and I
don't know what to make of it because
it's not as though I did anything
brilliant you know what I mean it's not
like I did some clever things that made
it all work or I hid a bunch of
difficulties that I then knew exactly
what to do because I'm so whatever I
just did just work for me so but I would
also argue that people have been working
on all of these bits of software and
also that you know what you're doing
with repositories and updating different
modules and you used a completely
different operating system sure and like
I said yeah like I know those things I
like I have that knowledge some of it
but I didn't have to use it I suppose
what I mean by that isn't necessarily
that you've been tweaking because of
course you just told as you haven't but
my my experience was that the distro
that I used with the particular version
of kdenlive on the particular hardware
that I had did work out of the box but
not in all the areas I needed it to
that's interesting I'm rendering out was
one of the areas I needed it to work so
one of the things one of the one of the
decisions you make when you're choosing
a distro is there's always a trade-off
between being up-to-date and being
stable right and arch and arch based
distributions generally are they call
them bleeding edge right because
generally speaking you get the latest
version of the software so having the
latest version you're probably going to
have the most stable you can have the
most bug fixes in place but also the
most new features that people are trying
out and a lot of software projects do
use a system where they have major
releases well I said I used a long term
support release of Ubuntu
exactly exactly however it was 12
for which people was telling me was out
to date at the time it wasn't the latest
major release well it was a thing they I
think the latest long-term release at
the time was fourteen Oh something okay
and I couldn't get that to work at all
so the long-term release didn't work now
I'm not going to open up the hornet's
nest but I will just say that I believe
it to be something to do with graphics
card drivers and I shall walk away at
that point ya know I mean this is the
kind of thing I do I do feel really bad
for people who have to deal with that
like the people who work in work on open
source software having to deal with the
fact that people are going to install
graphics cards which are undocumented
right like that the manufacturers keep
as a closely guarded secret exactly how
it works and if they don't provide a
driver or if they do that driver is just
a binary blob that you can't you know
you can't look inside it doesn't tell
you're any useful information and they
have to make something that works
flawlessly with this tremendous are
fantastically complicated will be like
or how it would be implemented or
whatever the idea of this paper is that
it it lays out some problems that we can
tackle now which will be helpful now and
that I think will be helpful later on as
well with more advanced AI systems and
making them safe as well